MODERATOR: Now i'm going to give you remote control Okay, and whenever you're ready, you can start reading the first task and I will start a timer.
P5: Okay, so like you said it's a bit awkward.
P5: screen.
P5: Okay, so the first task.
P5: What you see on your screen or two panels with labels left panel and main panel.
P5: One read the text within home tab in the main panel allowed an explorer data source of your choosing by right clicking and opening it in a new tab.
P5: Once you feel you understand where the data comes from please click the button open map to visualize the density of data points within the locations of interest or you will be done when you mentioned a few of the lies that have data points available so.
P5: So retention text within the home tab.
P5: So I have to read the text in the home tab and.
P5: Let me just check okay.
P5: The sc dashboard heights the complexities in linking clinical rare disease data with environmental observation using knowledge graphs the desired outcome is to support health that are researchers identify appropriate environmental variables.
P5: To enable their hypothesis exploration in researching our diseases, how to use the dashboard one selecting submit query inputs on the left.
P5: to explore the resulting linked environmental data that appear after clicking submit three export the data for your needs text file name user query history dot txt is is automatically saved in your APP local folder with the history of your query input selections.
P5: You will be able to use this file to get the data directly through the API in the future data environmental observations have been gathered from the following sources, whether pollution aerosol data right click was opening to.
P5: See data point density click the button hover over the regions to get the number of data points okay so that's the homes have read.
P5: clicking an opening.
P5: Read text from the whole time explore data source of your choosing so today I source, are these things.
P5: So right clicking into a new tab.
yep.
MODERATOR: yeah it's fine.
P5: yeah i'm.
P5: Open that up.
P5: So.
P5: Just i'm just going to zoom out here are a few minutes or.
P5: So it's a map of where sorry I forgot I clicked on I think I clicked on whether um yeah I clicked on whether so it's the white with the weather data.
P5: kind of from the following sources so.
P5: And for boy, these are letters station boys.
P5: 2820, I guess, these are.
MODERATOR: Remember what the task is asking just to acknowledge what data come from just.
MODERATOR: You have to go too deep into this.
P5: Oh sorry I.
P5: Once you feel you understand where the data comes from.
P5: Sure um yeah so it's just yes just wider data Okay, yes okay so okay.
P5: Okay, so let's go back here so says no, I can open my to visualize the data points.
P5: Okay.
P5: Sure, so he's just a bit awkward because.
P5: it's not a problem with the APP it's just i'm working on one screen, just so you know that, for your analysis okay i'm.
P5: Okay yeah I see no that's that's fine yeah I got what's going on here, so this is just whatever.
P5: Actually, what is this data click this.
P5: Okay, so it's just a number of data points right for each for each county okay okay yeah and then the.
P5: Blue so.
P5: Lucian okay so each each stars a tennis racket map I got to see what each how much of each data point there is.
No.
P5: there's a little bit like here I sure whatever okay um.
P5: The otherwise stuff data points available.
P5: yeah so I mean each county I guess they're kind of divided up into counties.
P5: each other number of data points available okay um, so I think that's the first test on so okay yep okay cool um.
P5: So I can submit a query using the inputs, the input options available in the query tab on the left, most panel.
P5: While you're selecting the query options, please explain a load the specific choices, you make, as you make choices new ones will become available for you to select.
P5: Once you reach em please click the submit button once which will only be available invalid inputs have been selected.
P5: You will be done when a new tab named q1 is displaying the main part of the dashboard please only submit one query okay so submit query using the input options available in the query tab on the Left okay.
P5: Let me just.
P5: zoom up again.
P5: Okay query yet so that's already there it's been a query isn't.
P5: When you're selecting the correct right, so I can select the options.
P5: So if our solution is rare disease so there's only one option, I could vasculitis that's fine.
P5: Events of interest flare there's a little.
P5: tool tip I guess.
P5: Oh, oh OK that explains the type of the ad yeah.
P5: How intense the flares can turn this off yeah I think there's better like sorry anyway.
P5: yeah okay now I can okay so definitely high probability possible or no um.
P5: might be good if there was like an option, an option for like all of these I guess.
P5: location of interest so yeah this is okay again just what county i'm guessing oh sorry I haven't Okay, I said sounds blacked out because I don't click anything okay there Oh, we can we can select more than one oh, I see okay okay okay yeah.
P5: There we go I should I should yeah i'm okay location of interests Kevin Tony go.
P5: Open okay yeah So these are all the options available and Darren has way more than the orders.
P5: you're doing this just telling me that there's these are where the flares are.
P5: Okay, this is where I select location of interest yeah so let's say let's just click Claire we don't.
P5: think that was here.
P5: Actually let's let's let's let's do that okay.
P5: Okay, and I can select more than one yeah okay there's a tick box here saying ireland's.
P5: i'm not sure what that means, unless the some of these locations of interest or outside of Ireland.
P5: yeah I don't know i'm gonna stick it anyway, why not.
P5: And this is the date range so yeah like whatever.
MODERATOR: So just make sure you understand why you click Ireland.
P5: I don't know.
MODERATOR: Okay okay.
P5: Well yeah like I say i'm not sure why is there actually are correspond, so I.
MODERATOR: Just clicked it then no problem, and then we can discuss it later.
P5: Okay okay that's fine i'm.
P5: Okay.
P5: Start they want to go back.
P5: date range I can't go back these are all great out, so I kind of go back further than a certain date, maybe that was maybe I was explained somewhere or say seventh of January until.
P5: Sunday June 2020 until the sixth of August I think there's a bit of like again.
P5: up there, we go.
P5: And these are the data sources I wants, whether on the same boat, whether i'm solutions, and I can choose what temporal units I want so let's say I want just won't see.
P5: And then the aggregation method use Okay, this is pretty handy So what do I want the mean of the monthly weather and pollution or where are the men are the Max of the monthly what our pollution.
P5: Or the daily or and so on okay so let's just say the mean Okay, and there is some if I can click some important, so I said submit.
P5: What was another do that, I think.
yeah.
P5: Oh yeah okay so once you raise your hand, please click the submit button once okay that's fine which will only be available valuable selected, you will be done when a new tab name q1 is displayed in the main part of the dashboard okay.
P5: So I think this, this is probably q1.
P5: we consume up.
P5: yeah this is q1 okay cool I think that's the that's task completed them.
MODERATOR: yep.
P5: Okay cool tasks on my street exploring q1 tab in order to understand the table underneath there are two buttons that help you interpret the data table that you see.
P5: click both buttons on top open query input Sumerian open color table description commenting allowed on their usefulness and clarity as explanations and read the text in the data soap tub.
P5: and talk through the interpretation of variables and solid background colors red and blue of the data table.
P5: You can select the columns that you want to display with the toggle columns button note that you can scroll vertically and horizontally and use the page arrows.
P5: On the right bottom corner to check the amount of data you're querying quick you queried by scrolling you will be done when you feel you sufficiently explore this table okay so explore the key ones hub okay that's fine.
P5: Let me just sorry something just reposition my screen a bit.
Okay.
P5: Okay, so explorer key one tab.
P5: In order to understand this table, there are two buttons to help you interpret the data literacy click buttons on top.
P5: So these two buttons here open query input summary so let's just click this button here.
P5: query input summary.
P5: Okay, so it's just this just repeats okay why what my query was.
P5: that's fine and open.
P5: This the second button here open quarter table description.
P5: Oh.
P5: Oh sorry sorry, a new thing appeared at the bottom there sorry okay table coolers.
P5: Data table background if data is normally is no issue 95% between minus two plus two is that scores white okay values more than two are high red values less than minus two are low blue okay so that's that's fine.
P5: Okay, there we go.
P5: Okay that's fine so.
P5: year, so I see there's a year column the month column I selected on a monthly basis.
P5: And then I have all the difference whether variables here.
P5: and
P5: So these tables are based off right that the yeah so the standard, these are we're assuming they're normally distributed on if they're set scores are.
P5: More than.
P5: Okay sorry so yeah I see I see yeah there's that scores are more than 200 if there's that scores are less than minus two then or blue okay that makes sense, so we can easily see any.
P5: outliers.
P5: So, to speak Okay, what else we have to do.
P5: commenting on their usefulness and clarity as well yeah commenting on are useless clarity of explanations, I think the destinations are fine.
P5: And yeah.
P5: then read the data read read the text and the data soap tab and talk through the interpretations variable cell background colors okay I kind of already done that you can select the columns that you wanted to display with the toggle columns button okay toggle homes.
P5: Okay, so this lets me okay just display.
P5: Which columns they want so let's say I want to get rid of nfl.
P5: sugar.
P5: yeah let's say I want to get rid of them so or order which is rain outs appear want to get rid of temperature.
P5: Okay yeah.
P5: Okay yeah that's that's that seems handy i'm.
P5: Not the scroll vertically and horizontally and use page arrows on the rock right bottom corner.
P5: These things.
MODERATOR: For me, is for me to monitor.
P5: Oh sorry.
MODERATOR: You want to take it.
P5: away there we go okay.
P5: says their arrows in the bottom right corner don't quite see them.
P5: You can scroll vertically and horizontally and use the page arrows.
P5: To check the amount of data that you acquired by score scrolling.
P5: Sufficient explore this table okay.
P5: screen.
P5: There was a.
MODERATOR: Time fine.
P5: Okay that's fine yeah well.
P5: yeah just let you know I couldn't quite find that okay so task for.
P5: exploring the other tabs inside the tabs beside the data tab all three plots time series box on polar plot or interactive features for different purposes.
P5: Please use those features for each part, while mentioning the usefulness of each one and understanding the environmental data, you will be done when you have explored through the interactive features for each of the three.
P5: plots ABS okay so just just look at each of the plots okay full screen.
P5: Time series.
There we go.
P5: Okay, so this is fairly self explanatory, let me just read it ties response visual story long time this visualization is interactive.
P5: Okay zoom over single and multiple patterns and world as a dot PNG file legends click on the variable to select the select a Double Click is to select only.
P5: Just yeah okay Okay, Nice and then I can.
P5: Okay, I can zoom in on a certain feature of it yeah race later click and drag okay so it's all right.
P5: zoom over.
P5: oops.
P5: Okay clicking of interest in the bottom.
P5: Oh yeah okay.
well.
P5: yeah okay okay that makes sense okay so that's still fairly self explanatory.
P5: box blah okay so it's just a box plot of the data.
P5: And let me just read this the box bounce the quarter arranged by the by the median and two key slow Westerners extend to a maximum of 1.5 by the IQ are we on the box this visualization interactive so I can hover over these this gives me.
P5: And the quintiles and the two key whiskers.
P5: OK, for each variable that's that's fine.
P5: Okay cool and I can I can download these things here as a PNG so on okay polar plot.
P5: scatter plot complex variable when dependencies.
P5: radius indicates the wind speed and the reason, when direction this visualization is interactive okay so have to select some to make disappear so so that's right.
P5: Okay, let me just read this again scatter plot.
P5: scatter plot complex variable wind dependencies the radius length indicates the wind speed and the degrees of the wind direction.
P5: Okay Okay, so this is this is blowing the wind Okay, so what direction the wind is going.
P5: wind speed and the degree radius and the length of the radius is the speed okay.
P5: And so that you could use this, I guess, to find the correlation between the wind and the rain or the wind and whatever else.
P5: So there seems to be more rain and, of course, and then the intensity of the rain is indicated by the heat the heat of the chatter plots.
P5: Okay that's fine in this interacts as well, I can look at all these different points.
P5: Of these are all taken a different time so I might also be useful to know like when like on site.
P5: So it gives the wind speed and the rain, maybe if the if the tab also shows.
P5: When these points were like if they were early in the year, maybe I don't know, maybe I won't be useful not sure.
P5: Maybe it will be way wouldn't be okay, but either way okay that makes sense, so let me just go back to the tasks.
P5: That was every task, for I think you.
P5: Know okay that's fine okay that's number five creating your queries after you have submitted them following the same instructions step to you'll see q2 q3.
P5: As a new tab in the main panel Now you can compare them and the comparative tab read the text in this tab and select the number of groups, you wish to make then click.
P5: On the click to generate groups born anew inputs PR group will appear underneath arranger queries in the groups and click on click to plot groups now new soaps, new sub tabs.
P5: will have appeared three different visualizations please mention allow the usefulness, each one in a similar manner step three.
P5: Okay, so just make some new queries okay so.
P5: Okay, so I can't change these let's just.
P5: Just to be different let's just go for possible.
P5: let's select Carl.
P5: I don't know what I still don't know what that date range.
P5: let's go back to April 1.
P5: To August 1.
P5: let's say just whether let's say whether I say daily and let's say a minimum.
P5: submit.
P5: that's q2 that's fine and let's say for the q3 let's say, the only thing I want to change is, I also want to look at the maximum.
P5: Okay, so that makes q3 whoops.
P5: Okay that's fine, so I can use the comparative tab, let me just.
P5: Now you can compare them comparative tab read the text in this tab and select number of groups, you wish to make okay so let's have a look for the comparative tab.
P5: curtis.
P5: Okay, a query data previously submitted in this session can be compared by specific variable you can combine these queries into groups with the multiple selection inputs to potentially increase the signal to noise ratio.
P5: You can combine these queries into groups with multiple said okay fine so one decide the number of groups that you wish to compare.
P5: to select queries you want to group three explore each environmental variable with different plots.
P5: queries are grouped by computing mean per unit time and the time series and concatenate the values in the box and box plot, and in the box and districts are therefore at the time series plot has a limitation when comparing queries with different climates.
P5: So we just have a quick look at the top of the sorry the tasks again.
P5: So read the top task resistance times like numbers group, you want to make then click generate new groups, a new inputs PR group will appear underneath.
P5: Okay number of groups.
P5: 100% sure.
P5: What exactly i'm doing to be on but let's just see what i'll probably figure out what's really.
P5: So I just select the two groups.
P5: Okay, so I can select group one.
P5: Okay, so right the groups are the queries okay so let's just say q2 for groupon and q3 for group to.
P5: So the dish The only difference between those is that q2 is minimum maximum yep so let me just.
P5: Say that might be interesting, I guess i'm.
P5: click to generate groups, a new inputs PR group will arrange your queries in the groups and click on plot OK, so now, I can plot these groups.
P5: Alright, so next variables to group.
P5: Okay, so i've got a few.
P5: Okay, so let's look the temperature.
P5: Okay, so this is yeah yeah Okay, I see what's going on now so that's just the way of like comparing yeah yeah okay so.
P5: Group to yeah so go to his q3 so that was the maximum that's the minimum that's fine yeah and they seem very correlated you will guess, and I can select whatever he wants let's look at the box plot again let's look us rain.
P5: group one rain okay.
P5: You have a look so yeah so.
P5: Okay Okay, so this is me. Okay, so it shows a scatter of the points and and a box But OK that's fine a little bit confusing i'm fair enough um yeah, I think, personally, I would just prefer just the box on its own and.
P5: that's just my preference i'm sure everyone has their own and that's fine.
P5: yeah okay that makes sense.
P5: Okay, just not sure what this is let's.
P5: sum PM PM 25.
So.
P5: that's a glitch or if i'm not understanding something.
MODERATOR: Remember, which was able to query.
P5: q2.
P5: So.
P5: Creative so the difference between them is minimum maximum so the distance is now.
MODERATOR: What what body what data sources, did you query for quality quality.
P5: And it was the weather data.
P5: So.
P5: You know it's not i'm not sure what the dist even should be.
P5: yeah okay so i'm not i'm not sure what they said, or I would show.
P5: I was open to pollution data or something else.
P5: Is.
MODERATOR: it's fine it's fine.
P5: it's fine okay okay that's fair enough.
Okay.
P5: Okay yeah so yeah the other two were fine I kind of got them and I kind of understand what on here so i'm not even sure what this would even what does even supposed to show, to be honest, so yeah.
P5: Anyway, moving on.
P5: To our sex six choose one of the queries to export q1 q2 q3 go to a tab that the export button from the data table and download the data csv file finally opened the zip download tab on the Left panel and click.
P5: On download zip with all data tables to download all data for all the queries submitted during the session as as a file you'll be done with understanding, where its data store okay so choose one of the queries to export and go to that tab okay so let's say I want to.
P5: Take you one want to download to you want Okay, I was away, I can download this click the export button at the data table.
P5: yeah so here.
P5: there's an export button.
MODERATOR: Yes.
P5: On your computer.
MODERATOR: i'm just gonna come soon Thank you yeah.
P5: Okay cool.
P5: It makes sense i'm right what's next thing finally.
P5: Finally, opened the zip download tab.
P5: On the left side panel to click and download zip with all data table so there's I remember seeing this.
position.
P5: Okay, here, that is download is it with all data tables.
P5: stored in our files okay.
Okay.
P5: You will be done okay so that's fine um so task seven Finally, could you summarize earlier overall.
P5: Your overall your experience in completing these tasks, using the seed, seed dashboard then Please proceed to complete the PS Su Q questionnaire okay so um.
P5: yeah, let me just go back in the full screen here yeah it's all fine and this all makes sense, it seems easy enough to get the hang of i'm.
P5: Always back here again so yeah so this.
P5: I think it was fairly.
P5: intuitive.
P5: query stuff is good.
P5: yeah i'm not sure what else you got I still don't know this Ireland button means.
P5: Whatever that's fine I, being able to download everything is good.
P5: yeah the ui dates, this is kind of Nice being able to see just offhand how much data, there is, and this is nice as well being able to see where the data is like how much data, there is for each county and so on.
P5: yeah i'm all the stuff I will it yeah like being able to take the you know.
P5: able to select other time granularity and the aggregation method is good, maybe that like I mean there's older aggregation methods of course older than the main in the maximum mean you could have the median and all that but uh.
P5: that's kind of splitting hairs you know.
P5: And I don't even know like what are the main is okay, or the meetings Okay, but yeah maybe maybe just a couple more options will be kind of Nice now and the query tables yet they're all falling and so being able to look at your query again just remind yourself.
P5: yeah.
P5: This all seems fine I mean this this is.
P5: The one thing i'll say so, this is a these out these outliers are determined by a normal distribution like we're assuming they're only distributed there's no reason to think that these are normally distributed or I mean you know it's not a big deal there might be.
P5: better ways to like identify outliers you know what I mean because.
P5: it's not like I said there's no reason things is normally distributed um.
P5: But it's it's not a big deal, you know just I understand it's just some kind of quick.
P5: kind of way just to see Okay, so any values, who are much lower than we'd expect are much higher than we expected that's fine and it's doesn't it doesn't have to be super sophisticated thing the plots are good yeah the port applause nice actually because.
P5: That is something that kind of came up, I know that comes up a bit like wind and that's not something i've ever looked up before, but I know other people have you know what I was.
P5: There was a disease in Japan, where it turned out wind was the secret the secret ingredients to figure out what causes so um yeah it's kind of Nice that we're looking at wins, I think this might be important or might not be but it's nice that's there anyway.
P5: And yeah the comparative FAB is good, so, in fact, different theories and yeah, these are all fine.
P5: Maybe.
P5: Can I select more than one.
P5: Although well Okay, I was gonna say no, you select more than one variable at a time might be handy but I don't know it probably wouldn't be, as I said, with the box part I kind of just prefer.
P5: yeah just an oral blogspot on its own, because that's informative and.
P5: I still don't know what this this is supposed to be, obviously I couldn't go to work because maybe I use the wrong word, but I did some wrong, but I.
P5: yeah but even if, even if it was working i'm still not sure why it's supposed to be so yeah that everything else seems kind of fine.
P5: And it's not say like working through this it hasn't been super responsive but that's probably because we're working over zoom and i'm controlling raleigh so I can't I can't read your shot fairly.
P5: Well yeah This seems.
P5: pretty good i'm just wondering what order things just occurred to me there.
P5: It might be handy if there was like I know we can select as many as we want here.
P5: Or maybe that's what I heard in those hold on.
P5: Okay, I see Okay, so all if you want all of Ireland, he selects ireland's okay Okay, maybe.
P5: That could be very clear yeah.
yeah.
P5: yeah okay that's that's every no yeah It seems pretty good pretty nicely so yeah thanks.
Okay.
MODERATOR: So i'm gonna thanks for doing this and want to stop sharing.
P5: that's fine.
So.
MODERATOR: i've been over to stop sharing for you.
P5: And it's still sharing.
MODERATOR: yeah.
P5: It says i'm still controlling your screen as well.
MODERATOR: Okay, can you not click the zoom and click another window.
MODERATOR: let's see if I can, if I can do it this way yeah.
MODERATOR: Okay.
P5: yeah.